Ray Stevenson the Irish actor who's
arguably best known for playing volstag
and Marvel's Thor movies has died at the
age of 58 variety has confirmed details
about the cause of Stevenson's death are
unknown as in the making of this video
but the news was verified by his
publicist
the actor was born in Northern Ireland
in 1964 and moved to England with his
family when he was eight years old he
attended the Bristol Old Vic theater
School graduating when he was 29 before
pursuing a career on the screen and
Stage after making a name for himself on
shows such as a woman's guide to
adultery and a Dwelling Place Stevenson
got his big break in 1998's the theory
of flight the rest is as they say
history in 2004 he joined the cast of
King Arthur and his Hollywood career
took off from there leading to roles in
some of the most high-profile franchises
in history Stevenson had a storied
career in film and television it was a
renowned character actor whose list of
credits boasts everything from
blockbusters to hit TV shows but his
work with Marvel helped turn him into a
household name he played the Asgardian
adventure of volstag and Thor in the
sequels the Dark World and Ragnarok the
character was a member of The Warriors 3
and friendly with the titular Norse God
and his brother Loki
it is not wise to keep two Infinity
Stones so close together
full stag isn't the only Marvel role
that Stevenson brought to life though
his first foray into superhero movies
wasn't as family friendly as the Thor
films in 2006 he portrayed Frank Castle
and Lexi Alexandra's Ultra violent
Punisher war zone an underappreciated
action her that has gained many fans in
cult movie circles Stevenson also had a
recurring role in the Divergent series
and the Scott Atkins LED accident Man
Saga most recently the actor played the
antagonist in rrr and fans can look
forward to seeing him posthumously in
the Epic drama 1242 Gateway to the West
Stevenson also deserves to be remembered
for his television work which includes
Star Wars projects and acclaimed
historical dramas he famously played the
Roman soldier Titus pulo on HBO's
historical drama Rome from 2005 until
2007. series 1 7 Emmy Awards during its
22 episode run and Stevenson's
performance certainly contributed to its
success the actor also appeared in a few
episodes of Dexter back in season 7
playing a Ukrainian mob boss the later
seasons of Showtime serial killer drama
might not be the most well regarded by
fans but Stevenson's performance was
prey used and even earned him a Saturn
award nomination for best guest actor in
a television series Stevenson had a
knack for playing compelling bad guys
and he brought those sensibilities to
the galaxy far far away for Star Wars
Rebels and the Clone Wars which saw him
voice the treacherous Mandalorian gar
Saxon fans of the Sci-Fi franchise can
also look forward to seeing him play a
character on Disney Plus's upcoming
Ahsoka series which is set to Premiere
this August Disney and lucasfilm haven't
released a lot of information about this
character yet but he is expected to be a
villainous Brute
foreign
[Music]